فقط ننوه بهذا الخبر نقلا عن مراسل
الجزيره غارات اسرائيليه تستهدف سهل
القليله جنوب مدينه صور اللبنانيه ونتابع
معكم هذه
الصور غاره
جويه
غاره غاره
اذا ما نشاهده الان هي غارات اسرائيليه
تستهدف سهل القليله جنوب مدينه الور
اللبنانيه هذه اثار هذا القصف الاسرائيلي
اذا الذي يستهدف للمره الاولى مدينه
سور سهل القليله جنوب مدينه سور
اللبنانيه غاره
غاره جويه ومن بلده رميش جنوب لبنان مدير
مكتب الجزيره مازن ابراهيم اذا واضح ان
هناك تصعيد يصل الى عمق الجنوب اللبناني
صيده وصور حدثنا عن اخر المعلومات
والتفاصيل لديك
تفضل نعم في الواقع ليلى كي نكون دقيقين
جدا نحن نتحدث عن قضاء صيدا وقضاء سور
بمعنى ان الغاره التي شهدناها في كوثر
السياد هذه الغاره هي استهدفت قضاء صيده
وليس مدينه صيدا هذا اولا ايضا الاستهداف
في سهل القليلي هو جنوبي مدينه سور بطبيعه
الحال هذه الاستهدافات هي استهدافات لافته
جدا هذه الاستهدافات غير مسبوقه تحديدا
عندما نتحدث عن كوثر السياد ايضا جرى
اطلاق صواريخ وغاره من الطائرات الان في
هذه المنطقه هنا تحديدا حيث سنحاول من
خلال عدسته الكاميرا ان ندخل الى بلده
عيتا الشعب كي
نرى الصواريخ التي اطلقت من قبل الطائرات
والمقاتلات الحربيه الاسرائيليه دعينا
نجمل ليلى ابرز هذه التطورات التي حصلت
خلال الساعه الماضيه وهي تحمل دلالات
كبيره على عده مستويات ان تصل الغارات الى
بلده كوثر السياد وهي في قضاء مدينه صيدا
تبعد عن مركز قضاء صيدا اي عن مدينه صيدا
نحو 7 كت يعتبر هذا الامر بانه تطور نوعي
في عمليات العسكريه لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وللاستخدام التي تطلقها باتجاه
البلدات اللبنانيه ان تصل الى هذا العمق
فهذا تطور كبير ايضا بعدها بنحو 10 دقائق
جرى استهداف سهر القليلي وهو هو على مقربه
من مدينه سور الى جنوبي مدينه صور
وبالتالي الاستهداف الاول والاستهداف
الثاني يحمل دلالات كبيره بمعنى ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باتت تطلق صواريخها
باتجاه محيط مدن رئيسيه وفي مناطق متقدمه
على مستوى جنوب لبنان بطبيعه الحال
الغارات ايضا شملت عتها الشعب وهو هذا
الدخان الذي نراه في الافق هذا نتيجه
للصواريخ التي اطلقت عليها هذه البلده
بالاضافه الى مجموعه غارات اخرى استهدفت
بلده راميه استهدفت العديسي وغيرها وايضا
يارون وغيرها من البلدات التي جرى
استهدافها من قبل الطائرات الاسرائيليه كل
هذا التطور يحمل رسائل متعدده من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باستهداف هذا العمق
من جنوب لبنان بحيث بات مستباحا امام
الصواريخ التي باتت تطلق في اكثر من مكان
واكثر من منطقه لابد من الاشاره ايضا ليلى
الى ان كل هذه التطورات تاتي بعد العمليه
المركبه والنوعيه التي نفذها حزب الله
صباح اليوم والتي من خلالها استهدف مركز
قياده رئيسي على مستوى
الطائرات قياده الطائرات العسكريه
والعمليات الجويه التي تنفذها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سواء في لبنان او في
سوريا وقبرص وتركيا وكل
ساحل البحر الابيض المتوسط الساحل الشرقي
نتحدث عن تلك المنطقه عمليا العمليه التي
تم تنفيذها من قبل قوات الاحت من قبل حزب
الله تجاه هذه ال القاعده العسكريه
الاسرائيليه اعتبرت هنا في لبنان وفق
قراءات عديد من المحللين والخبراء
العسكريين بانها عمليه نوعيه مركبه تم
اطلاق مجموعه من صواريخ الموجهه من نوع
كورنت في البدايه لاشغال القبه الحديديه
ومنظومه القبه الحديديه من بعد ذلك تم
توجيه راجمه صواريخ كامله نتحدث عن 32
صاروخا اعقبها راجمه اخرى من منطقه اخرى
وكلها صبت صواريخها بذلك الاتجاه وهو ما
دفع حزب الله الى اصدار هذا البيان الذي
اشار فيه الى ان هذه العمليه التي نفذها
انما هي تاتي كرد على الاغتيال صالح
العاروري في في في ضحيه بيروت الجنوبيه
وبالتالي يمكن القول بان كل هذه التطورات
جاءت متسارعه على مستوى الجبهه اللبنانيه
وهي يحمل دلالات كبيره على حجم التصعيد
الذي نشهده